at the edge of the bank cease it's the
ruins of the Constanta casino with only
hints of its former grandeur this MEP
hopes heritage sites across Europe will
see better days a repo arranged it with
public delivery so correct
Adam Itachi she identity Nazi O'Neill or
component ally in Europe a nationalist
you passed rent she rediscovered in
return plus one seller Europe na karein
net a Doudna mythical he you lawmakers
have made 2018 the European year of
cultural heritage with a specific budget
set aside for it
it's a year where cultural groups
heritage organizations and youth can get
electively involved educational and
cultural activities will take center
stage challenges will be highlighted
from lack of funding to illegal
trafficking of artifacts MEP s also want
to rev up the economic potential some
300,000 people in the EU work directly
in the sector and about seven point
eight million jobs are indirectly
created portraitist food elation spoon
culinary industry a Gucci Bowl the
future adults
jakka News says there's a lot of work to
be done a year dedicated to Europe's
tangible and intangible treasures is a
start